Bourbon Express histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée c'est vous qui nous la
racontez elles amont d'ingava c'est
l'histoire d'un retour très controversé
oui ce soir je vous raconte l'histoire
d'un retour annoncé reporté finalement
un retour surprise un retour très
contesté ce matin les députés membres de
la commission des affaires étrangères
les étudiaient un rapport sur le corps
diplomatique alors c'est très
intéressant mais pas de quoi non plus
faire la une de tous les journaux sauf
que très vite il y a un député dans la
salle de commission qui va très très
vite attirer l'attention ce député c'est
lui les entouré en rouge à l'image c'est
Adrien catenens député condamné pour
violence conjugale il est suspendu de
son groupe des insoumis jusqu'au mois
d'avril il siège donc à présent
aujourd'hui parmi les non inscrits et il
était donc à cette réunion évidemment à
ce moment là une fois que l'information
a futé tous les journalistes se sont
pressés devant cette commission qui
n'est pas ici dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale elle est dans une
rue juste derrière Adrien catenin on
l'attendait on voyait présent bien en
commission on se demandait s'il allait
sortir avoir une porte dérobée ou s'il
allait bien passer devant la presse et
bien un peu après 13h il a décidé de
venir de passer et de répondre au
journaliste alors
aujourd'hui
j'applique la décision prise par mon
groupe politique voilà merci à tous et
bonne journée
une petite phrase et puis s'en suit et
bien 300 mètres au patch pour rejoindre
son bureau à l'Assemblée nationale
entouré vous le voyez d'une meute de
journaliste on lui a demandé s'il
comprenait que son retour puis choquer
pas de réponse il s'est contenté de dire
ce qu'il nous avait dit face caméra
qu'il ne faisait qu'exercer son travail
de parlementaire la regarder il va il
rentre dans son bureau à l'Assemblée
nationale l'entrée donc remarqué c'est
impressionnant la forêt de caméra qui
l'entoure les réactions nombreuses on
l'imagine oui évidemment alors une des
premières à dégainer c'est Aurore berger
Aurore berger c'est la présidente du
groupe Renaissance Adrien ce n'est
toujours pas encore sorti de la
commission mais elle improvise une
conférence de presse juste devant le
bâtiment il est accompagné de Sacha
aulier c'est le président de la
commission des lois il n'est pas
question de laisser passer ce retour
sous silence écouter
on avait peut-être l'espoir un peu naïf
qu'ils comprennent de lui-même que sa
place n'était plus évidemment au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui au
lendemain même d'ailleurs de la
présentation du projet de loi de réforme
des retraites par le gouvernement il
juge sa présence
utile il juge sa présence évidente il
revient comme si de rien n'était au sein
de la commission des affaires étrangères
il est une évidence pour nous encore une
fois que sa place ne peut plus être à
l'Assemblée nationale ne doit plus
l'être et la réponse politique c'est ça
cette proposition de loi distribue à
tous les journalistes présents pour
créer une peine d'innél éligibilité en
cas de condamnation pour violence
conjugale alors au sein de la nuque
évidemment ça réagit aussi Sabrina
sebahi elle est porte-parole des
écologistes elle était présente en salle
de commission lui a demandé bien comment
elle avait réagi quand elle a vu Adrien
quel a été votre réaction quand vous
avez vu Adrien katmain c'est arrivé dans
la salle en réalité j'ai été très très
étonnée parce que enfin on n'avait pas
du tout eu vent d'un éventuel retour au
contraire un corps hier certains de ses
collègues enfin de ses collègues de la
France insoumise disait qu'il valait
mieux qu'il ne revienne pas
immédiatement et là c'était très
étonnant de le voir revenir ce matin
même en bas côté socialiste et
communiste qui visiblement n'était pas
non plus au courant il renvoie la
responsabilité au député plus largement
à son groupe même s'il précise bien que
chez eux ça ne se passerait pas comme ça
et le sommier alors ils étaient où les
insoumis ah bah les insoumises étaient
pas bavards pas bavard du tout
aujourd'hui on a essayé essayé allez on
a obtenu deux phrases similiées écoutées
effectivement c'est bref ce retour il
gêne il gêne la gauche qui elle aurait
voulu parler retraites toute la journée
et pas du cas d'Adrien